[Musik]
der presseclub mit jörg schönenborn
herzlich willkommen schön dass sie dabei
sind an diesem sonntagmittag wir
deutschen haben in den letzten jahren
gespart wie noch nie und da rede ich
jetzt nicht über die reichen die immer
reicher werden sondern ich rede über die
breite mitte der arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer gründe für dieses sparen
gab es viele die sorge dass im alter die
rente nicht reicht um den wohlstand zu
sichern der wunsch für eine wohnung oder
ein haus zu sparen dass man dann aber
wegen der hohen preise doch gar nicht
kaufen konnte in vielen branchen bot im
langen aufzug im langen aufschwung guter
lohn bezahlt aber für das geld auf dem
konto gibt es auch mit glück kaum mehr
als ein prozent zinsen wenn jetzt die
inflation auf satte 8 prozent steigt
sind viele menschen besorgt irritiert ja
haben wirklich angst um das was sie sich
mühsam erspart haben da war es schon
erstaunlich wie lange sich die
europäische zentralbank geziert hat an
der zinsschraube zu drehen diese woche
endlich am donnerstag gab es eine
ankündigung
0,25 prozent sollen die zinsen nach oben
gehen unser presseclub thema heute
mittag zinswende und inflation was
bleibt von unseren wohlstand und ich
freue mich auf diese gäste anja krüger
ist wieder bei uns ist
wirtschaftsredakteurin bei der
tageszeitung taz ich freue mich auf
heike göbel die bei der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung verantwortlich es
für wirtschaftspolitik markus gürne vom
hessischen rundfunk ist bei uns er
leitet die ard finanz redaktion sie
kennen ihn aus dem börsenstudio und
herzlich willkommen lisa nienhaus sie
leitet in frankfurt das büro der
wochenzeitung die zeit von nienhaus
nehmen wir die perspektive dieser
fahrerinnen und fahrer mal ein die uns
jetzt zuschauen die seen 8 prozent
inflation und unsere frage heißt was
bleibt von unserem wohlstand was ist
ihre antwort
im moment bleibt für die sparer
jedenfalls relativ wenig und dadurch
dass die ezb jetzt auch nur sehr langsam
handelt also sehr sehr langsam die
zinsen erhöhen mit
muss man befürchten ist dass eine weile
lang so bleibt also 79 inflation ist ja
schon ordentlich und da schmelz schmilzt
das vermögen das man auf dem konto
liegen hat dahin das ist so herr gerne
welcher schaden ist bereits entstanden
enormer schaden und zwar auf ganz vielen
unterschiedlichen ebenen als
gesellschaftlicher schaden entstanden
weil das vertrauen schwindet es ist
politischer schaden entstanden weil wir
sehen die rahmenbedingungen werden nicht
leichter es gibt da kommen wir sicher
später noch darauf verschiedene
überlegungen instrumente tank rabatt war
einer und es gibt natürlich den schaden
für die bürgerinnen und bürger wie vor
nienhaus das eben gesagt hat das wird
nicht besser werden weil die inflation
wird auch wenn sie ab sinkt in den
kommenden zwei jahren
deutlich über der zielmarke liegen die
die ezb ausgegeben hat und das bedeutet
wir werden eine situation erleben wo
menschen weniger schnell im besten falle
wohlhabend werden und das kann man nicht
mehr durch sparen erreichen sondern nur
durch finanzbildung zb wohlhabend sag
mal gehen nach lebenssituation sind sehr
unterschiedliche dinge heißen kann wen
hat es am meisten getroffen und bin
weniger frage also klar ist dass
inflation vor allen dingen die unteren
einkommensgruppen sehr stark trifft und
am ersten trifft weil die natürlich fast
ihr ganzes einkommen ausgeben müssen für
lebensmittel und die lebensmittelpreise
haben sicher sind jetzt wirklich stark
verteuert in den letzten monaten jeder
kennt das berühmte beispiel von der
tomate mit den 40 prozent aber es ist
auch alles mögliche andere und die
energiepreise kommen natürlich auch dazu
und die wucht wird jetzt glaube ich da
am deutlichsten spürbar ich denke viele
andere spüren ist vielleicht noch nicht
ganz so sehr die haben noch reserven in
der pandemie konnte man ja nicht so
viele dienstleistungen in anspruch
nehmen nicht so viel reisen also da
kommt glaube ich so die größere welle
vielleicht erst im herbst
den tritt kretschmann baden württembergs
ministerpräsident sagt viele werden
weniger geld und wohlstand haben und
diese verluste werden deutlich und
schmerzhaft sein und über jahre andauern
wie wird sich das äußern für die die
rücklagen haben wird es sehr ärgerlich
seien aber wirklich dramatisch wird es
für die menschen sein für die auch jetzt
kein wohlstand herr es gibt wirklich
bittere armut in deutschland da darf man
einfach die augen nicht verschließen
es gibt neun 160 tafeln die wirklich
sehr viele klienten haben weil die
menschen ansonsten es sich nicht leisten
können einkaufen zu gehen und für diese
menschen ist die inflation eben nicht
ärgerlich sondern wirklich dramatisch
und die situation verschärft sich da
ganz enorm einmal natürlich die
lebensmittelpreise die sind schon großes
problem aber das wirklich schlimme wird
im herbst kommen wenn die nachzahlung
anstehen für den strom für die heizung
also zum beispiel bei hartz4 empfängern
ist es so da werden die heizkosten
übernommen aber die stromkosten nicht
und da muss der staat sich wirklich was
einfallen lassen um das abzufedern
ich kann das gut nachvollziehen ich will
kurz eine grafik zeigen lassen sie mich
vorhin auch sagen nicht beschäftigt mir
die frage wenn man
man auf die tafeln schaut völlig richtig
dann haben sie recht die
hartz-iv-empfänger völlig klar auf der
anderen seite gibt es viele umfragen
nach denen das empfinden der
allermeisten menschen ist mir persönlich
geht es gut bei der landtagswahl gerade
in nordrhein westfalen hatten wir die
wählerinnen und wähler gefragt ich sehe
die grafik hier jetzt nicht wir haben
gerade keinen monitor im studio und da
kommt sie super danke
und wir sehen dass klar den fdp
anhängern gibt es am besten geht von der
afg fühlen sich ein bisschen weniger gut
aber sag mal am ende sind es auch bei
der bundestagswahl 180 90 prozent die
sagen mir persönlich geht es gut wie
passt das zusammen das empfinden mir
geht's gut und die wahrnehmung die sie
gerade geschildert haben also der eine
punkt ist dass die inflation ja noch
nicht so lange anhält das ist ja eine
relativ junge entwicklung und der andere
punkt ist dass der wirkliche inflations
hammer tatsächlich noch gekürzt noch
nicht ja da muss natürlich auch sagen
dass wir nach also wir haben ja
sozusagen den arbeitsmarkt schock der
pandemie überwunden die arbeit die
beschäftigung ist hoch es gibt viele
offene stellen das heißt die menschen
haben auch keine sorgen um ihren
arbeitsplatz das trägt natürlich
allgemein auch dazu bei dass man sich
weniger sorgen macht über die
wirtschaftliche lage trotz inflation
freundin aus und als angesprochen wir
haben einen wahren konsumrausch viele
menschen holen jetzt nach was auch zwei
jahren nicht möglich war ist das ja ist
das auch inflationstreibend ist das auch
ein grund für die steigenden preise oder
ist es eine folge weil ich einfach angst
habe dass man geld nichts mehr wert ist
er ich glaube das ist natürlich
inflationstreibend nun kann man es den
leuten auch nicht verbieten dass sie
jetzt nachdem sie monatelang sogar
teilweise jahrelang nichts ausgeben
konnten jetzt plötzlich irgendwie ihr
geld ausgeben wollen das wäre jetzt ein
bisschen schwierig dass ihnen zu
verordnen um die inflation niedrig zu
halten sollen sie jetzt bitte nicht so
viel konsumieren ich würde gerne nochmal
einmal kurz was zu ihrer umfrage
vorhersagen weil es gibt nämlich auch
noch eine andere umfrage da geht es
darum was sind ihre größten sorgen und
in dieser umfrage wo es um die größten
sorgen der deutschen geht da ist zuletzt
die inflation ganz oben angekommen da
ist es vielleicht so dass die leute eine
gute wirtschaftliche situation jetzt
haben aber sie sorgen sich sehr darum
dass es bald vorbei ist und diese sorge
ist höher in dieser letzten umfrage
gewesen als die sorge über den ukraine
krieg was ja schon doch erheblich ist
wieder ein bisschen verdrängt wird das
passt ja zu dem was früher gesagt hat
und ich glaube ich eine ganz gute
zusammenfassung der ersten runde also es
geht nicht darum dass ich jetzt schon
die volle wucht spüre sondern dass wir
alle zumindest an den zahlen sehen
können was auf uns zukommt dann kam der
donnerstag dieser woche für manche
endlich die ezb präsidentin christine
lagarde sagte bei einer sitzung des
zentralbankrats in amsterdam folgendes
september und sie sagt wir werden im
juli beschließen unsere zinsraten um
einen viertel prozentpunkt anzuheben und
wir haben vor im september weitere
beschlüsse in diese richtung zu fassen
dass die historische wende auf die alle
gewartet haben also ich bin als schwabe
auf die welt gekommen wenn sie da
landsmannschaftliche dann haben sie
diesen gendefekt mein geld schon im blut
ich würde sagen dass keine zinswende
sondern ein zinswende weil wir reden von
0,25 wenn es sehr gut läuft dann werden
wir am ende des jahres irgendwo zwischen
diesen 0,75 und einem prozent liegen
auch von - hatte er gesagt bei 8 prozent
inflation ist das ein sehr schwacher
trost was vor allen dingen sehr
ärgerlich ist finde ich sind zwei dinge
wenn man auch die ezb gruppen sehr sehr
zögerlich in der in den vergangenen
monaten deutlich zu spät findet auch mit
einer sehr unglücklichen und schwierigen
kommunikation
und auf der anderen seite sehen wir
inflation und deshalb passt dieses
werkzeug nicht unbedingt dazu ist vor
allen dingen auch getrieben weil wir im
windschatten der leute die gerne jetzt
konsumieren wollen sehen dass sich viele
unternehmen die taschen dadurch voll
machen und das gerne mitnehmen und da
ist dieses mittel dann nicht unbedingt
so zielführend ja ich bleibe noch mal
bei diesem zinsschritt danke erst mal
für ihre vielen kommentare in unserem
live streams bei presseclub de und
tagesschau.de
marlon berger zum beispiel fragt bei
twitter was bewirkt diese
zinsentwicklung eigentlich ganz konkret
also das passiert jetzt und dann gerne
von ihnen allen einschätzungen zu viel
zu wenig zu schnell zu langsam wir haben
ein sehr graduelle zinswende jedenfalls
wenn es bei dem bleibt was frau lagarde
angekündigt hat ist aus meiner sicht
eben auch zu langsam sie kommen zu spät
das heißt sie wird auch nicht so schnell
die wirkung entfalten über höhere zinsen
kann man ja preise nicht direkt lenken
sondern die geldpolitik wird wird
indirekt sie wird mit einer gewissen
zeitverzögerung und wir müssen
eigentlich erwarten dass noch über eine
längere zeit daneben real unsere
kaufkraft stark schwinden wird das auch
die fahrer freuen sich ja eigentlich
wenn es wieder zinsen gibt aber wenn man
dann natürlich guckt was ist real die
inflationsrate ist natürlich unterm
strich nach wie vor negativ und ich
glaube die aussicht ist dass es ein sehr
langsamer prozess wird der uns noch viel
nerven kosten wird und man auch nicht
genau weiß je nachdem wenn eben die
lohnrunden darauf reagieren und die
löhne vielleicht deutlich stärker doch
angehoben werden als vielleicht auch die
ezb kalkuliert dann könnte ja dann
könnte vielleicht auch die ezb noch zu
mehr zu einer schärferen reaktion
gezwungen werden aber im moment ist sind
ja alle erst mal froh dass sie überhaupt
reagiert und ja ich glaube daran ist
dauert ich finde man muss auf jeden fall
im auge behalten das ist ja auch
negative auswirkungen gibt ich finde
richtig dass die zinsen steigen weil ich
finde man muss wirklich etwas gegen die
inflation tun aber man muss sehen es
gibt natürlich probleme für
hochverschuldete staaten im euroraum
auch und es gibt natürlich auch für die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
probleme denn es ist erfahrungsgemäß so
die zinsen werden weitergegeben wenn es
um kredite darlehen geht dispozinsen zum
beispiel aber wenn es jetzt um die
sparzinsen geht das kommt mit enormer
verzögerung und das ist auch ein problem
das heißt es wird erst mal teurer es
wird für viele leute probleme geben die
zum beispiel kredite aufgenommen haben
und jetzt umschulden müssen und da reden
wir jetzt nicht von 50 euro im monat
sondern unter umständen von vielen
hundert euro und das ist auch ein großes
problem das muss man auf jeden fall
immer im kopf behalten das ist ein
problem aber darum geht es ja eigentlich
also das soll diese zinserhöhung soll ja
dazu führen dass kredite teurer werden
sie soll dazu führen dass man mehr geld
auf dem konto bekommt das nunmehr zinsen
bekommt also dass mehr gespart wird aber
auch dass nicht so viele kredite
aufgenommen werden das ganze ziel
dahinter ist wir
senden nicht mehr so viel geld in die
volkswirtschaft hin aus und das führt
dann dazu dass auch die preise sinken
also das ist ja einfach nur der wirkungs
weg da kann man jetzt beklagen dass es
diesen wirkungs weg gibt aber man muss
sich doch fragen was ist denn jetzt im
moment gerade das drängendste problem
ist unseren drängendstes problem dass
die leute moment ihre kredite nicht
bedienen können glaube ich nicht oder
ist unser drängendstes problem gerade
dass wir eine fast acht prozent
inflation haben und es gibt bekannte
ökonomen die sagen einem ab einem
gewissen punkt bei so einer hohen
inflation müssen die zinsen eigentlich
höher steigen als die inflationsrate und
davon sind weit entfernt
und stabiler geld wird ist ja sozusagen
die vertrauensgrundlage für die ganze
wirtschaft das heißt wenn das nicht mehr
gewährleistet ist und gerne hat ja schon
gesagt das vertrauen geht verloren man
hat anzeichen dafür in welchem maße das
weiß man noch nicht aber ich glaube die
zweifel sind sehr stark gewachsen in den
letzten wochen dass die geldpolitik
schnell genug reagiert und wir müssen
einfach uns alle klar machen dass der
anpassungsprozess nicht so leicht ist
und er wird uns auch was abverlangt und
da wird auch ein bisschen wohlstand
schwinden erstmal vorläufig letzte frage
von unseren userinnen und usern zum
thema inflation und versuchen schritt
weiter zu kommen dann ist mit dem
abflachen der inflation zu rechnen also
es wird im kommenden jahr losgehen aber
es wird auf einem hohen niveau losgehen
also ich glaube die letzten erhebungen
der bundesbank sagen für dieses ganze
jahr im schnitt von 6,8 prozent voraus
das ist enorm und im kommenden jahr geht
es dann irgendwie auf in richtung 4 und
dann 24 auf über 2 prozent immer noch so
dass am ende des tages klar ist wir
werden die nächsten zwei jahre in jedem
fall mit inflationsraten zu tun haben
die deutlich über der zielmarke liegen
die die ezb vor jetzt stellt sich die
frage wann wird der punkt erreicht sein
wo normale spart zinsen wieder dafür
sorgen dass man geld nicht an wert
verliert also ehrlich gesagt ich bin
jahrgang 1970 ich bin nicht ganz sicher
ob in meiner erwerbstätigkeit die noch
16 jahre andauern wird mindestens noch
zinsen in nennenswertem umfang
tatsächlich vorkommen werden aber dieses
ganze problem zeigt ja dass ist einfach
weitere massnahmen braucht also die ezb
ist eben ein ganz kleines instrument
von ganz vielen instrumenten die die die
europäische union aber auch die deutsche
bundesregierung einfach nutzen müssen
zum beispiel um die energiepreise in den
griff zu bekommen denn wir alle wissen
ja der eigentliche
inflationstreiber das sind die
energiepreise und daran kann man etwas
ändern die muss man nicht so hinnehmen
das stimmt ich glaube dass aber ein
großteil der inflation wie wir sie
gerade erleben vor allen dingen
getrieben ist auch durch unternehmen die
im windschatten der dieser dieser ganzen
krisen
gute gewinne machen das sieht man sowohl
was amerikanische unternehmen anbelangt
in studien als auch die europäische
zentralbank selber hat festgestellten
einer studie das im jahr 2021 die
gewinne und das sehen wir auch in den
bilanzen der unternehmen
wirklich gut nach oben gegangen sind
also die streichen schon auch ein teil 1
und dadurch dass dort die preise erhöht
werden heißt es auch dadurch steigt die
inflation und dann wird das mit
geldpolitischen maßnahmen an der stelle
eher schwieriger werden jetzt gibt es ja
verschiedene beteiligte die etwas tun
können wir haben jetzt über die
notenbank gesprochen wir sprechen
nachher noch über den start der im
moment weniger für die sparer tut als
für das tägliche einkommen aber es gibt
sie haben das gerade erwähnt die
arbeitgeber die unternehmen wir sind in
der situation dass wir anders als früher
oft bei inflation keine steigende
arbeitslosigkeit haben wir haben im
gegenteil wir haben massiven
arbeitskräftemangel wir merken das alle
täglich wenn der bus oder die bahn nicht
fährt weil es kein personal gibt wenn
restaurants nur wenige tage die woche
geöffnet haben falls kein personal gibt
es gibt
tarifauseinandersetzungen die vor uns
liegen im stahlbereich wo die gewinne
groß waren fordert die ig metall 8
prozent ist das nicht der nächste
logische schritt dass die
arbeitgeberinnen und arbeitgeber einfach
dafür sorgen dass durch deutliche
lohnerhöhungen stück davon aus gebieten
wird natürlich an einen effekt wird das
sein dass das die lohn dies dass die
löhne stärker steigen wenn die
arbeitskräfte knapp sind sollte man
diesen effekt ohnehin erwarten und ich
denke das ist im augenblick für manche
unternehmen schon fast das hauptproblem
dass sie eben nicht genügend nachwuchs
und ersatz kriegen für jetzt den doch
ganz für viele branchen ganz schönen
aufschwung
andererseits ist natürlich auch die
unsicherheit nach wie vor groß durch den
ukraine krieg durch die inflation das
heißt auch die unternehmen werden
vielleicht nicht ganz so also die werden
glaube ich ihre vorsicht vielleicht
nicht ganz so gerne aufgeben weil ein
bisschen zu verbrauchen und wenn wir
jetzt betonen wie schön viele und durch
die durch die pandemie gekommen sind und
wie hoch die gewinne sind ehrlich gesagt
wir wollen ja eigentlich auch dass sie
ordentlich gewinne machen damit zum
beispiel die stahlindustrie demnächst
vielleicht dann doch nicht so viel die
subventionen braucht um ihre grünen
hochöfen sichern die heißen anders aber
um diese sind sozusagen dient den
klimawandel zu bewerten zu bewältigen
und in sogar das schönste an hohen
gewinnen dass man höhere löhne zahlen
und damit die märkte im alltag
ausgleichen kann von ihnen aus verfolgen
also es ist wird auf jeden fall jetzt
passieren also die gewerkschaften werden
höhere löhne verhandeln
einfordern und sie werden auch
durchsetzen
das wasser wirkt das also was bewirkt
dass als in der folge und in der folge
gibt es natürlich eine große gefahr dass
das entsteht was man die lohn preis
spirale nennt das quasi die löhne
steigen dass damit steigen wieder die
kosten für die unternehmen die
unternehmen erhöhen weiter die preise
dass das passieren kann und auch in der
vergangenheit schon passiert ist das
müssen wir deswegen kann man jetzt nicht
fordern die leute sollen sich oder man
kann es schon ich würde es nicht tun die
leute sollen sich total zurückhaltend
mit ihren lohnforderungen aber lohn
preis spirale ist überhaupt nicht in
sicht ganz im gegenteil wir können davon
ausgehen dass es reallohnverluste gibt
also wenn man wenn wir sehen was ist an
abschlüssen in diesem jahr gegeben hat
und was es noch geben wird da die werden
nicht auf der höhe der inflation sein
und es ist ja die ig metall die wird im
moment das sind die stammbeschäftigten
aber die großen industriebetriebe
autobau und so das steht erst noch an da
hat ja schon die bundesregierung
versucht mit der konzertierten aktion
sozusagen die gewerkschaften einzufangen
und das wird sehr spannend denn es ist
eine ganz zentrale frage in den
vergangenen krisen in diesem jahrhundert
und das sei schon eine ganze menge haben
immer die beschäftigten und die bürger
die kosten der krise gezahlt und jetzt
ist die frage sind in einer multiplen
krise vielleicht demnächst in einer mega
krise wer zahlt die kosten für diese
krise lassen sie uns mal bei der fragen
bleiben wer gibt mir wie viel lohn mehr
also wir haben im moment 8 prozent
inflation herr gerne sagt das können
auch vier sein im nächsten oder
übernächsten jahr wenn es gut läuft also
das tut sozusagen die ezb mit mit in die
kasse als sie sorgt dafür dass es ein
bisschen runter geht wie viel prozent
lohnerhöhung sind dann angemessen um das
was mir an verlust bleibt auszugleichen
24 68 also ich finde was tut uns gut
dass es nicht gegen persönlich und uns
persönlich nicht arbeitgeberin
arbeitgebern was tut uns was tut der
gesellschaft befinden ist es ganz
wichtig zu zeigen das bild das wir gerne
ökonomischen buch als lohn preis spirale
benannt wird ihr genau umgekehrt das
phänomen ist die preise sind gestiegen
die löhne müssen nach sind das bild
dreht sich eigentlich um das haben einer
stahlbranche 8,2 prozent erhoffen an der
ig metall chef hat für die metall und
elektroindustrie die runde die im
september anstehende sagt das heißt
forderung wurde darüber und das ist
genau das dilemma einerseits die
kaufkraft der beschäftigten zu erhöhen
um die nachfrage auch weiterhin oben zu
halten und auf der anderen seite eben
was vor gehör vollkommen zu recht sagt
wir wollen alle wir haben alle ein
interesse daran dass unsere
volkswirtschaft weiterhin erfolgreich
bleibt mit diesem modell und was ich
wiederhole das finde ich sehr spannend
ist eigentlich das was man den 70er
jahren gesehen haben wir haben eine
situation dass wir eine hohe inflation
haben wir haben eine situation dass wir
eine wirtschaft haben die aufgrund der
rahmenbedingungen deutlich schwächer
unterwegs ist was wir aber im gegensatz
zu den 70er jahren haben ist dass wir
einen hohen fachkräftemangel haben wir
brauchen eigentlich fachkräfte und
deshalb werden wir tatsächlich glaube
ich sehen dass wir ordentliche
lohnabschlüsse haben die sich in dem in
dem bereich zwischen 6 und 8 prozent
tatsächlich ab sechs bis acht prozent
okay ist das also ich hab mir mal meine
frage war was wären minuten in der
situation in der sich der wissenschaft
prozent vergrößert was in der tabelle
geht und was vielleicht durch
einmalzahlungen noch ein bisschen
aufgestockt wird es wird sicher nicht
flächendeckend so sein wie es für die
gebäudereiniger ausgegangen ist die nun
gerade 13 prozent mehr gibt bekommen
haben und ist das eine sehr kleine
branche und die löhne sind sehr niedrig
da aber 13 prozent kann natürlich
flächendeckend jetzt nicht die antwort
sein
wollen sie noch nicht wollte beitrag
tarifauseinandersetzung lassen ich
wollte nur darauf hinweisen dass man
natürlich wenn wir jetzt überlegt was
wäre ein angemessen
lohnerhöhungen schon ein bisschen mit
berücksichtigen muss dass die
energiepreise ja durch den
ukrainer krieg wahrscheinlich auch nicht
für immer diese hohen preise erreichen
also deswegen gibt es ja auch die
überlegungen wassergewinnung gesagt hat
dass wir zum beispiel das ist
einmalzahlungen gibt also statt zu sagen
wir machen jetzt genau die inflation und
die machen wir auch genauer als
lohnerhöhung okay ich halte mal fest
weil das glaube ich ein wichtiger
bisschen auch trösten der gedanke ist
also es kann sein dass wir einen einen
peak gerade haben dass es an ja eine
einbuße an inflation gibt der gerade
durch besondere umstände kommt der sich
aber aus vielen gründen wieder etwas
abflacht dass es nicht so bleibt wie es
im moment ist und dann sagen sie wäre
was und gehälter angeht es sinnvoll wenn
sich die parteien darauf einigen dass
man für dieses jahr einen besonderen
ausgleich schafft auch langfristig
erhöht aber eben nicht so stark dass
gestatten sie mir noch ein sagt dazu ich
finde das sehr interessant auch da zeigt
sich die sozialpartner nämlich
arbeitgeber und gewerkschaften haben in
den vergangenen jahren und jahrzehnten
finde ich auch sehr gute art und weise
gezeigt wie man es schafft mit zwei sehr
unterschiedlichen interessenslagen auch
immer tatsächlich eine lösung zu finden
und ich finde man kann eigentlich auch
davon ausgehen dass es ihnen auch dieses
mal wieder gelingen wird jetzt haben wir
gesprochen über die bank jetzt haben wir
gesprochen über unternehmen ich glaube
mal öffentlicher dienst aus weil da
keine gewinne anfallen sondern im
gegenteil wir einen
staatsschuldenproblem haben aber wissen
wir das ist jetzt mal ein sonderthema
dass ich aus so jetzt lese ich hier bei
unseren userinnen und user die frage was
kann denn der staat tun das ist
sozusagen der dritte player über den wir
sprechen wollen er hat diese woche
wieder etwas getan es gibt eine lange
liste aber ich fange mal mit einem
beschluss des bundesrats vom freitag an
das ist nämlich die erhöhung des
mindestlohns hat erstmal gar nichts mit
der inflation zu tun sondern die spd
hatte das bei den tarifverhandlungen bei
den koalitionsverhandlungen durchgesetzt
es gab viel kritik und irritation weil
es eigentlich eine kommission gibt die
das macht aber jetzt sagt die politik
wir greifen ein und erhöhen den
mindestlohn auf 12 euro das sind gut 20
prozent aufschlag
nach dem was wir gerade besprochen haben
ist das überhaupt nötig wenn
arbeitskräfte fehlen wenn bei
gebäudereinigern 13 prozent ohnehin
drauf kommen also ist das ein mutiger
überhaupt wirksamer schritt offenbar
denn es gibt 6 66 millionen menschen die
davon profitieren werden und daran sieht
man ja das ist offenbar nicht gelingt
das dass der markt dafür sorgt dass es
einen vernünftigen grund lohnt gibt
und es ist aber gleichzeitig so dass der
mindestlohn eigentlich nicht genug
steigt auch wenn der schritt jetzt
wirklich groß ist der dgb hat das mal
ausgerechnet also für einen single
arbeitnehmer sind es zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt 220 euro mehr das klingt ja
schon viel also jemand der 40 weil nur
sehr sehr wenige von denen sechs
einfachen zusätzlich 1,8 millionen und
wenn wir jetzt uns mal überlegen was
passiert mit diesen 220 euro ja da
werden wahrscheinlich die ersten drei
monate für die nachzahlung der strom und
energie und der heizkostenrechnung
draufgehen und die inflation wird
wirklich auch dauerhaft davon viel
aufregung noch ein paar schippen
zusätzlich vom staat gibt das stimmt
aber auf dauer ist es schon so dass die
inflation nicht eingepreist ist und man
muss sagen dass dieser mindestlohn auch
gar nicht ausreichten jemand dass ein
leben lang bekommt dass er am ende eine
auskömmliche rente hat und das finde ich
muss doch wohl der maßstab sein dass
jemand der vollzeit erwerbstätig ist
zumindest lohn dafür dann eine rente
über der arbeitslosen und so der maßstab
sein wenn ich ein wenn ich widersprechen
dass sie vielleicht nicht wundern wird
zum einen halte ich diese mindestlohn
erhöhung die ja außerplanmäßig war und
auch einem versprechen den man bei der
einführung des mindestlohns 2015 auch
seitens der spd gegeben hatte nämlich
dass der mindestlohn eingeführt wird mit
8 euro 50 und dann eine mindestlohn
kommission diesen
die erhöhung schritte vorschlägt und
zwar entlang der tariflohn entwicklung
dieser tarife und entwicklung greift
jetzt der staat noch ein weiteres mal
vor mit einem ganz ordentlichen schritt
wie wir gesehen haben und meines
erachtens treibt er damit quasi selbst
die in nation ein ganzes stück weil es
eben so zusagen von unten eindruck gibt
auch auf die tariflöhne man sieht das an
den gebäudereinigern übrigens schon
ich glaube auch nicht dass die messlatte
sein muss dass jemand dein ganzes leben
zu mindestlohn lebt ich glaube wir
sollten einen höheren anspruch haben wir
sollten sehen dass wir über
qualifizierung versuchen dass das eine
phase ist aus der mann rauskommt und
außerdem haben sie ja eben auch gesagt
in einem land wo arbeitskräfte knapp
werden müsste sich eigentlich auch die
unteren löhne müssten sich deutlich
bewegen und die werden sich auch bewegen
und die haben sich auch schon bewegt und
nur deswegen ist die wirtschaft ja im
moment so entspannt weil sie sagt ein
teil dieser mindestlohn dieses
mindestlohns sprungs den hätten wir
sowieso machen müssen jetzt in nächster
zeit um einfach die arbeitskräfte noch
zu kriegen mit anderen worten ich halte
diesen politischen eingriff für verfehlt
weil ich glaube dass ist einfach nicht
da aber nienhaus unter gerne hören wir
auch dazu ich sag nochmal es sind seit
2005 10 seit der einführung jetzt gut 40
prozent die der mindestlohn gestiegen
ist wie viel schaden dafür nutzen ich
wollte einfach nur einwenden dass ich
glaube genau wegen dem was sie gerade
gesagt haben ist es eigentlich jetzt im
moment gar nicht so ein großes problem
dass er gestiegen ist wir haben sowieso
und druck von unten wir haben sowieso
druck auf die löhne die die steigen und
sie haben eine hohe beschäftigung ich
glaube es gibt zeiten da kann man total
dafür argumentieren das muss unbedingt
niedrig bleiben der mindestlohn aber
irgendwie sind diese zeiten da habe ich
nicht das einzige was stimmt dass das
natürlich der inflationsdruck dadurch
noch mal steigt aber ich weiß nicht wie
erheblich das ist würde das
unterstreichen da in welchem teil ist
immer die frage in welcher zeit sind wir
unterwegs ich glaube im moment ist es
tatsächlich so dass das gerechtfertigt
ist die große frage ist ja tatsächlich
wie stark soll der staat sich eigentlich
einbringen und aussehen wird das haben
sie gesagt an ganz vielen
unterschiedlichen initiativen die sorge
die ich so habe es ist gut dass es einen
starken staat gibt das ist auch gut dass
er sich engagiert wenn man sich die
krisen der vergangenen jahre an guckt
muss man trotzdem so ein bisschen darauf
achten weil sie kriegen mit ständig
wiederkehrenden krisen die auch tief
gehen auch die größte und stärkste
volkswirtschaft wie deutschland
irgendwann blatt also finde ich brauche
man auch die großen leitlinien und
vielleicht kommen wir noch dazu aber das
sieht man bei diesem
handwerklich aus meiner sicht eher
misslungenen konstrukt tank rabatt dass
man es auch anders machen kann sie
österreich da wird der preis einmal
festgelegt einmal am tag um 12 uhr
dürfen sehen erhöhen und ansonsten nur
noch senken also frage ich mich warum
macht er das denken dass es riskant ist
wenn man vor jeder bundestagswahl quasi
mit mindestlohn erhöhungen in indien in
den wahlkampf geht weil damit sind die
löhne einfach sehr stark politisiert
lassen wir mal außen vor das ist ein
wahlversprechen wahr das ist ein
systembruch ist dass man noch nicht
wusste wie hoch die inflation ist als es
denn wirklich kommen würde wenn wir das
mal weglassen können wir uns darauf
verständigen das ist für eine gruppe die
stark betroffen ist ein wichtiger
schritt ist wo der nutzen größer sein
könnte als der schaden oder gehen sie so
weit nicht mehr
mit einer enthaltung
so und jetzt wir sind weiterhin beim
start ich lese all die fragen danke das
schön danke für das dankeschön dafür was
kann der staat konkret tun
schreiben sie immer wieder ich habe
versucht ein paar sachen aufzuschreiben
die eeg-umlage fällt weg die energie
pauschale für ärmere haushalte der
hartz4 zuschlag der kinderzuschlag
verschiedene freibeträge bei der steuer
höhere pendlerpauschale senkung der
spritsteuer nennt man auch tank rabatt
fast umsonst bus und bahn fahren bin
sicher dass es nur ein kleiner
ausschnitt war eine sehr fleißige
bundesregierung haben die sich sehr viel
ausgedacht und sehr viel in die welt
gesetzt hat blicken wir mal ob das
positive was ist ihr persönlicher hit
bei den maßnahmen wohl sagen sie ja das
ist es das ist zielgerichtet und
sinnvoll ja wir wollen nicht immer nur
kritisieren
auch jemand sagt vielleicht hat jemand
anders
persönlicher ist die neuen euro ich
meine das macht es wirklich einfach
irgendwas sagen einfach schon dass das
ist eine ersparnis und es ist für drei
monate lang ein vollkommen unkompliziert
gebrauch des nahverkehrs also was will
man mehr das ist wahr und dessen
bezahlen muss und das erhöhte druck
endlich an diese infrastruktur anzugehen
damit man auch wirklich spaß damit hat
wenn man es benutzt weil man sieht ja
jetzt auch welche defizite daraus
entstehen weil infrastruktur zb ist eine
sache das wäre hoch notwendig aber ich
finde das ist auch ein erster wirklich
guter schritt erledigen seine
auswirkungen das darf man glaub ich
natürlich gelang das vergisst man sehr
schnell für für gerade haushalte mit
geringem einkommen sind mobilitätskosten
anteilig sehr hoch und es ist ja so zum
beispiel beim jobticket oder beim
semesterticket oder wenn man sowieso
einer monatskarte hat bekommt man den
differenzbetrag erstattet
und das wird sehr viele haushalte
entlasten neben was uns von anderen
irgendwann ist es wirklich wichtig ich
habe eine verkäuferin im bus getroffen
die erzählte dass sie normalerweise 137
euro abgebucht kriegt und diesen monat
nur 9 euro gut also dass mal ein bitte
jetzt sind sie ja
ich bin echt tschuldigung jetzt bin ich
negativ ich bin glaube ich nicht so ein
fan das neue neurotiker oder anderen
weil ich finde ich verstehe gar nicht
wieso man im tank rabatt wirft man vor
dass da auch irgendwie alle von
profitieren auch die gutverdiener beim
neuen euro ticket ist dann irgendwie
egal dass auch alle möglichen wirklich
auch viele gutverdiener in großstädten
auch davon profitieren also wenn man
wirklich will dass die
kliniken entlastet werden die wirklich
hart getroffen werden natürlich kann man
das deutlich zielgerichteter tun als mit
so einem neuen euro ticket dass ich
jetzt persönlich auch sogar besitze aber
ich finde es nicht nicht die allerbeste
ideen nur damit keine missverständnisse
gibt ich gebe ihnen völlig recht aber
ich würde sagen also für mich persönlich
ist sozusagen das was ich am sofort
spüren von diesem von von diesen ganzen
entlastungen und insofern würde ich
einen unterschied machen zwischen dem
was ich persönlich davon habe und dem
gut ich es politisch findet dass man
diesen weg geht denn ich finde es ist
nicht zielgenau genug und das hat auch
noch ein paar andere nebenwirkungen okay
dass neun euro ticket hat pluspunkte
bekommen ich merke ansonsten fällt ihnen
relativ schwer vielleicht hat es mit der
fülle der maßnahmen zu tun spontan
lieblingsprojekte zu nennen aber ich
greife gerne auch die kritik am tank
rabatt auf wir haben es heute in der
tagesschau gesehen robert habeck ist
jetzt aufgefordert worden sich zu
kümmern er will irgendwelche
kartellregeln
verändern
herget elf von 92 tagen tank rabatt kann
man schon eine bilanz ziehen oder ist es
zu früh sicher zu wissen was er bewirkt
also ich glaube nicht dass es ein großes
erfolgsmodell war es gibt ja in der
frankfurter allgemeinen sonntagszeitung
eine etwas andere sicht aber es gibt
ganz unterschiedliche maßnahmen wenn man
mit menschen spricht dann ist jedenfalls
die überwiegende eindruck das ist
irgendwie geschichte zwischen nicht
erfolgreich und wir werden hier über den
tisch gezogen
ich hatte es ja gerade schon erwähnt ich
glaube das war handwerklich nicht gut
gemacht weil es nicht so ein erfolg ist
es kommt jedenfalls nicht als erfolg bei
den menschen an und ich glaube wenn man
nicht weit woandershin guckt dann kann
man sehen wie man das möglicherweise
erfolgreicher gemacht hätte und der
versuch jetzt den herr habeck
angekündigt hat ist ja auch eine frage
wie lindert mann oder wie kann man das
ein wenig entschädigen was da jetzt so
handwerklich nicht gut geklappt hat und
für mich wäre das entscheidende dass man
aus solchen fehlern lernt und sie dann
nicht noch mal wiederholt ich denke auch
dass der tank rabatt wahrscheinlich die
größte die größten schwächen hat wir
haben noch die energie pauschale von 300
euro die wird ja immerhin dadurch dass
man sie versteuern muss sozial ein
bisschen angepasst ich denke das ist
dann eine akzeptable maßnahme beim tank
rabatt sind ist genau das eingetreten
was man befürchtet hat man kann nicht so
genau sehen oder gefühlt kommt unten
nicht so viel an wie gedacht das
bundeskartellamt hat am freitag noch mal
gerechnet und demnach kommt der
überwiegende teil dann doch an aber wer
weiß es man muss vielleicht auch die mal
einen monat abwarten oder 23 aber die
regierung kann auch nicht viel tun sie
könnte die ganze maßnahme wieder
zurücknehmen da hätte sie wahrscheinlich
noch mehr schaden wenn sie das jetzt
täten also es ist genau das könnte das
schlechte maßnahme die man gemacht hat
nein ich glaube nachbessern kann sie
eben nicht weil sie kann weder das
kartellrecht so schnell verändern und
dann womöglich noch so dass es die die
mineralölkonzerne jetzt trifft die
mineralölkonzerne sitzen wenn ich mich
recht erinnere auch nicht alle in
deutschland sondern er sonstwo in der
welt und an den hohen gewinnen wenn sie
denn auch hierzulande anfallen
partizipiert die regierung natürlich
also insofern soll sie sich nicht
beschweren da muss ich jetzt einfach
durch also zum beispiel in spanien läuft
das so bekommen dann die kunden den
rabatt an der tankstelle abgezogen das
ist ja das modell was ursprünglich der
herr lindner auch wollte und das ist
offenbar
und da ist so wissen sie aber dass ihr
den ich vorher draufschlagen das war ja
die befürchtung ersten war ja dass man
auch als chris muss man natürlich sind
das muss man natürlich handwerklich als
gesetzgeber auch vernünftig machen dass
es auch ein gewisses monitoring- gibt
aber es gibt ja schon modelle da mag es
vielleicht sein dass die
mineralölgesellschaften da auch
mitnahmeeffekte haben aber dann haben
die bürger wenigstens was davon und das
ist ja im moment einfach nicht gegeben
vielleicht war es ja absehbar dass egal
was man beim thema tanken tut dass die
heftigsten diskussionen auslösen würde
bei fragen von tank preisen von
besteuerung von sprit seit jahren
politischer sprengstoff sind deshalb
also danke für die meinungen dazu ich
bin gespannt wie wir das dann im
september beurteilt haben werden aber
die frage ist was fehlt also ich habe
dieses paket genannt wie gesagt das ist
schwer zu überblicken in der
gesamtwirkung des meister allerdings
hilft mir in diesem jahr 2022 und
insofern kommt die bundesregierung jetzt
zwangsläufig an den punkt entscheiden zu
müssen war es das und nächstes jahr
tragen dass alle selbst weil die preise
vielleicht wäre ein bisschen gesunken
sind also also ich weiß das ist was was
zwingt ist ist dass man unten quasi die
hartz 4 sätze anschaut und guckt wie
schnell man da weiter drauflegen muss
auch da hat es ja zu laden gegeben ich
denke das ist aber auch wirklich die
maßnahme die am wichtigsten wäre und die
zwingend ist was ich nicht verstehe ist
dass es jetzt wieder überlegungen gibt
auch von oder so halbe ankündigungen
seitens des arbeitsministers man bis
weit hinein in die mitte noch mal
nachlegen wollen und ich glaube da muss
man aufpassen man muss unten dran gehen
und die mitte muss das glaube ich jetzt
selber schaffen also bei hartz4 ist
eigentlich das prinzip dass ein grund
standard des lebens gesichert ist und da
so verstehe ich sie müsste man einfach
gucken wie viel muss man dagegen darf
der realität er mit elf jahren land
leidet ist und das herz verändert wäre
einvernehmen land ist okay und ich finde
es ein ganz wichtiger punkt freundin hat
das angesprochen
das ist dieses kann dies kann im prinzip
was wir eigentlich immer haben und da
sind wir uns ja weitestgehend
tatsächlich ja auch einig dass man
zielgerichteter dort hingehen muss wo
man es wirklich benötigt und es gibt
eben auch in einem land wo es auch doch
viele menschen gibt die das absolut zwar
ärgerlich finden aber die es nicht mehr
als spüren die brauchen das eigentlich
nicht und da bin ich vollkommen bei
ihnen die müssen und können das können
es vor allen dingen auch ertragen sie
müssen auch weil ihn der mann wird es
sehr teuer immer ich finde wichtig dass
man das auch nochmal einmal ökonomisch
argumentiert also sozusagen nicht nur
acht die müssen das jetzt tragen sondern
es ist auch so wenn der staat jetzt
versucht für jeden das auszugleichen
diese hohen preise wenn wenn das quasi
das ziel ist damit würden wir die
inflation wirklich massiv an schieden
noch weiter anschieben weil dann passen
die leute ihr verhalten überhaupt nicht
an aber ich finde es muss auch was getan
werden für die sogenannten
normalverdiener die leute die mit einem
kredit ein kleines häuschen auf pump
gekauft haben die gerade so über die
runden kommen und die jetzt zum beispiel
mit den energiepreisen wirklich in die
bredouille geraten und da finde ich es
gibt ja den vorschlag eines gaspreis
deckels ich finde dass man da wirklich
drüber nachdenken muss das bedeutet bis
zu einer bestimmten grund abnahme ist
der preis gedeckelt und der staat kommt
dafür auf und alles was darüber
verbraucht wird dann dem marktpreis und
ich glaube dass das ein ganz wichtiges
instrument wäre um tatsächlich auch ja
die normalen bürger zu entlasten
ich versuche mal zusammen zu fassen weil
wir in die schlussrunde kommen also wir
haben über eine tarifrunde gesprochen
die aus ihrer sicht in diesem jahr etwas
mehr bringen sollte als dann langfristig
an erhöhungen wir waren uns gerade einig
dass die unterstützung der bedürftigen
angeht der hartz iv empfängerinnen und
empfänger wir haben kurz darüber
gesprochen was ist jetzt mit der mitte
vielleicht zum schluss dass noch mal die
perspektive bald ich hier viel auch in
unseren rückmeldungen darüber lese
energiepreise sind der treiber sind der
hauptpunkt
wir haben sehr billige energie gehabt
auf kosten von demokratie in russland
auf kosten des klimas
auf kosten anderer teile der erde
insofern nach vorne geblickt
wird die inflation irgendwann etwas
korrigiert haben was vielleicht in die
falsche richtung gelaufen ist
also ich glaube schon dass wir ein
bisschen jetzt sehr stark beschleunigt
was sehen was wir vielleicht sowieso
gesehen hätten dass die energiepreise
ansteigen aufgrund auch der wende hin zu
grüner energie ich glaube das hätten wir
das hätten wir sowieso über längere
frist gesehen und natürlich hat das hat
das einen effekt dass jetzt plötzlich
durch die hohen energiepreise sich
dingen lohnen die sich vorher nicht
gelohnt haben und dass dinge
beschleunigt werden weiß ich nicht
ausbau der windkraft et cetera und das
kann man ja alles gut finden finde ich
auch gut nur das problem ist dass das
jetzt auf eine weise art und weise
schnell geht das dass die leute dann
doch überfordert am ende oder nicht alle
aber einige frau bärbel eine rosskur
aber vielleicht am ende mit der
richtigen wirkung
das kann man glaube ich vorab noch nicht
so genau sagen denn eine rosskur das
klingt doch sehr bedrohlich und ob dann
genügend menschen da mithalten können
und ob da nicht doch vielleicht auch
unternehmen in die knie gehen denn ich
meine man kann ja über die hohen gewinne
klagen aber eben letzten endes hängen da
auf der arbeitsplätze dran und das ganze
gesicht heitz gefühl auch die ganze
sozialpolitik wird halt aus diesen
gewinnen finanziert und insofern bin ich
ein bisschen skeptisch ist bewegt ich
glaube ich in die richtige richtung
meine frage also rosskur aber am ende
werden wir manches korrigiert haben was
falsch es kommt darauf an was jetzt
politisch noch passiert also wenn es zum
beispiel eine über gewinn steuer geben
sollte dann würde ich sagen ist auch der
weg eingeschlagen dann kraft richtig
gerne also rosskur auf jeden fall und
bei allen bei allen schwierigkeiten die
wir haben muss man sagen deutschland ist
ein ausgesprochen wirtschaftlich starkes
land wir werden am ende auch nicht
umhinkommen viel geld von dem was auf in
den privaten konten liegt und es werden
dieses jahr etwa neun millionen euro
seien mit werkzeugen so
aktivieren müssen dass auch das mit
einfließt bedanke mich sehr herzlich und
stelle fest also ich es aber unser
presse q presseclub parlament hat oft
mit mehrheit manchmal einmütig
festgestellt was noch zu tun wäre danke
dafür wenn sie in der ard bleiben jetzt
das europamagazin unter anderem mit
einem blick auf die parlamentswahl in
frankreich und wenn sie uns bei phoenix
oder im radio treu bleiben dann
presseclub nachgefragt dankeschön dass
sie dabei sind schüsse und lassen sie es
mich hin
[Musik]
und willkommen zurück presseclub
nachgefragt und radio bei wdr 5 im
fernsehen bei phoenix und natürlich im
netz und aus senftenberg ist kerstin
weidner daffner danke dass sie dabei
sind ihre fragen oder anmerkungen ja
hallo
senftenberg bei cottbus möchte ich
betonen weil meine frage ist gegen
definieren die jeweilige wohlstand wir
kämpfen hier ums überleben
tausende menschen haben wir meiner
umgebung angst vor den nächsten
mieterhöhung 1000 menschen bei denen
kommt dieser tank rabatt den namen finde
ich schon frech gar nicht an und und und
unsere preise in den einkaufsmärkten
steigen rapide wir wissen nicht mehr
weiter die tafeln klink zuspruch alles
klappt auch den ipad kammern wo ich dann
definiert und die frage an die junge
frauen noch von der frankfurter
allgemeinen
sie haben ja recht wenn es einen
mindestlohn gibt müssten alle anderen
löhne erhöht werden ich lade sie aber
gern in die realität ein das passiert
nicht im gegenteil man sucht nach
umwegen um diesen mindestlohn noch zu
kitten wieder in dem man die leute
gerade gebäudereiniger in die leiharbeit
flohmarkt geschickt und oder
ausländische mitbürger nimmt was mich
noch besonders wütend macht die gehen
nämlich nicht vom mindestlohn arbeiten
und alles andere nach oben wird eben
nicht aufgestockt und wenn man dann
sieht die leute nach 47 jahren arbeit
dass die mit einer rente er nach hause
gehen da muss ich wirklich sagen derzeit
definieren die mir wohlstand in meinem
umfeld wir haben existenzangst und ob
die mitgekriegt haben alle dass ich die
mittelschicht so wie wir sie kennen gar
nicht mehr
danach können angelangt wo wir haben
wohl danke erstmalig schlapp aber sie
bleiben in der leitung so und ich würde
jetzt zunächst vor krüger bitten
wohlstand zu definieren denn sie hat es
heftig genickt als verwalter sich zu
wort gemeldet hat und dann ist frau
göbel dran mit der frage ob tatsächlich
die
löhne dann auch angeschoben werden also
ich würde die wohlstands grenze da
ziehen wo hubertus heil das gemacht hat
als es um die frage ging wer denn diese
300 euro klima geld kriegen sollte oder
200 euro nämlich bei einem einkommen von
4000 euro es wäre der durchschnitt ja
genau und ich würde sagen dass natürlich
wer über dem durchschnitt liegt der hat
schon auch einen relativen wohlstand
ansonsten ist wohlstand natürlich auch
eine sehr subjektive sache ich finde
aber tatsächlich dass menschen die angst
haben um ihr existenzminimum der kammern
von wohlstand überhaupt nicht reden das
ist einfach auch
zynisch und da geht es ja tatsächlich
auch nicht darum jetzt einfach sich
irgendeinen luxus nicht mehr leisten zu
können sondern einfach nicht über über
die runden zu kommen und da bin ich auch
sehr dafür dass der staat tatsächlich
mit zulagen dafür sorgt dass sich da was
ändert rebell also das existenzminimum
ist sicherlich nicht wohlstand da gebe
ich ihnen völlig recht und dass man da
gucken muss davor was ich glaube ich
sagen muss das gesetzlich
vorgeschriebene löhne eben nur dann
funktionieren wenn unternehmen eine
möglichkeit haben damit auch am markt
erfolgreich zu sein das ist in einer
marktwirtschaft so dass ich denke in der
augenblicklichen situation werden wird
dieser mindestlohn sprung auch einen
effekt haben auf die niedrigen löhne in
anderen bereichen und die werden zum
teil auch steigen aber das wird
sicherlich nicht überall der fall sein
und in strukturschwachen gegenden und
ich bin nicht ganz sicher aber ich
glaube eben ein paar probleme sind da
tatsächlich in den neuen bundesländern
zum teil noch größer als in anderen
teilen des landes wird man womöglich
auch die negativen effekt dieses
mindestlohn sprungs führen spüren
ja hallo ja ich wollte ihnen wenn sie
mögen noch die gelegenheit geben einmal
zu kommentieren denn sie haben
aufmerksam zugehört danke aber sie
werden ja nicht mit allem einverstanden
sein
kriegen wir die wenigsten muss ich dazu
sagen weil man ist ja auch schon so
schlau wenn der mindestlohn angehoben
wird werden die stunden runter gesetzt
und und also man hat hier schon regeln
ich kann auch die mutter zusammen ich
kann auch kleinunternehmen verstehen die
dann sagen ich kann einfach diesen
mindestlohn nicht weiter zahlen weil
dann komme ich wirtschaftlich an meine
grenzen und wir werden gerade auch hier
im osten viele kleine zum haben dies
nicht mehr leisten können die kaputt
gehen und ich muss mal so sagen deswegen
habe ich das bewusste werk mit den
mieten wir gehen noch nicht mal den
urlaub reisen oder wie auch immer bei
uns geht es um die nackte angst unsere
wohnung zu verlieren und wäre nicht
berlin wir sind nicht treten und
nebenkosten der grund bieten wir können
auch die vermieter verstehen dass die
sagen ja wir schaffen das nicht mehr
aber wir sind in einer spirale drinnen
wo wir wirklich
daran
vielen herzlichen dank finde es wichtig
dass sie das geschildert haben ich
glaube vielen geht durch den kopf welche
versprechungen der bundesregierung
vielleicht an der stelle helfen können
und welche nicht und von mir noch eine
bemerkung ich glaube ihr anruf macht
auch deutlich wie unterschiedlich das
regional oft ist nicht also wo
in manchen regionen man auch für 15 euro
kann personal bekommt und wie es
anderswo eben auch aussieht verwalten
danke gruß nach senftenberg und ich
sorry aber schuss und ich würde sagen
springen sozusagen ja was nicht 67 800
900 km weiter westlich nach
mönchengladbach dann ist der bäcker
guten tag frau becker 58 es geht nicht
um stritt es geht nicht um mittelschicht
das geht ganz bestimmt nicht im
wohlstand die frau war das ganze schon
beschrieben auch die antwort fand ich
relativ gut es geht schlichtweg um
lebensmittel die menschen können die
lebensmittel nicht mehr bezahlen ich
kann es auch nicht und insofern gehen
die tarifverhandlungen findet so zynisch
von tarifverhandlungen hat man
gesprochen wird und die politik nicht
raus aus dem thema inflation
die müsste handeln da muss man angreifen
da muss man auch da gesetze verändern
nicht unser freies spiel der kräfte und
wir sind auch ihre diskussion weit weg
von den menschen die frau weiter aus dem
herzen gesprochen
ich möchte endlich dass man wirklich auf
den boden zurück kommt das auch schon
mal musste ich habe selber so die
rheinische post für die westdeutsche
zeitung gearbeitet dass journalisten
begreifen das geht nicht um ihre
interessen um das was sie binden denn es
geht um die menschen auf der straße die
das nicht mehr aushalten könnte schäden
meine bitte hin zu gucken es geht um
lebensmittel darum geht bedanke mich
sehr herzlich auch das ist noch mal ein
wichtiger und dringender appell und
vielleicht gerade deshalb wichtig weil
so viele eben das gefühl haben dass es
ihnen persönlich so gut geht und
deswegen finde ich ist diese schärfung
des blicks auch besonders wichtig danke
groß nach mönchengladbach
und dann sind wir in datteln bei georg
von malottki guten tag
ganz gut sagen so eine größe und nach
die erste anruferin ich hab nämlich
damals 1997 in senftenberg meinen
führerschein gemacht aber ich möchte
auch was angriffs hinaus und erwin dass
rauch frage eine frage an frau bärbel
und zwar möchte ich jetzt einfach mal
zur diskussion stellt wie man die sparer
schützen kann und das haushaltsdefizit
des
staates verringern könnte und da möchte
ich weiß das ist jetzt ökonomie aus der
klamottenkiste tbe einfach nur mal
stichwort ray dynamix zur diskussion
stellen hoch sind politik spalten jutta
finke zwei fachleute unter sich frage es
angeloben fr göbel lacht und sagt was
sie davon hält also die inflation nutzt
ja den den der verschuldung der staaten
jetzt erstmal weil die dort ja dadurch
weniger trägen wirkliche also die
staaten tragen ja weniger schwer an
ihrer in ihrer hohen verschuldung
insofern haben die ein gewisses
interesse daran dass die inflation noch
eine weile hoch bleibt weil das hat
natürlich da entlastende effekte auf die
tragfähigkeit der schulden für die
sparer ist es bitter weil man hofft
natürlich sehr auf die zinswende aber
man sieht eben die große diskrepanz
zwischen der inflationsrate und dem
bisschen was da jetzt als zinsen langsam
am horizont auf scheint insofern fürchte
ich ich habe da keine gute lösung ich
würde noch eins dazu sagen
gegen die inflation kann eine regierung
nicht so viel machen das muss in erster
linie die geldpolitik machen und da
liegt der ball
ok danke für den diskurs und beginnen
nach göttingen zu michael guten tag
sagen dass wir unser geld
meine frage vielleicht ein bisschen
provokativ aber trotzdem wie die
bezeichnung nation zurecht und
kaufkraftverlust als etwas negatives
passieren bekämpfen müssen aber wenn wir
uns ehrlich machen müssen wir anhand der
an der gesichte klimakrise nicht
eigentlich sagen wir müssen das als
unvermeidlich akzeptieren wenn
letztendlich müssen wir runter mit den
emissionen wir müssen runter mit energie
und ressourcenverbrauch und letztendlich
auch mit dem konsum dann wenn wir es für
dasselbe geld weniger konsumieren können
dann heißt das effektiv inflation und
müsste man nicht also sozusagen die
andere seite müssen meine ich andere
instrumente erwägen wie etwa opel
rationierung jetzt endlich das hat in
der krieg wirtschaft in der
vergangenheit und geschichte sehr gut
funktioniert und wollte von der
bevölkerung hoch akzeptiert
die ganze frau nienhaus haben sie eine
meinung dazu privaten man muss jetzt
ganz stark sein aber
kaufkraftverlust nicht nur negativ sehen
also die ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht
natürlich also ich sag mal den anstieg
der energiepreise da kann man so sagen
das hat eine gewisse lenkungswirkung da
wollen wir vielleicht auch hin dass
energie ein bisschen teurer wird damit
sich andere energieformen lohnen also da
würde ich an der einen stelle würde ich
mitgehen aber ansonsten würde ich sagen
was was bringt es denn jetzt für die
veränderung unserer unserer wirtschaft
und unserer lebensweise in die
lebensmittelpreise steigen also ich
glaube das bringt einfach nur das
gesamte gefüge der volkswirtschaft
durcheinander wenn wenn die preise auf
so breiter front steigen und da ist
keine mitgeholfen also ich wusste
überhaupt nicht was der positiven sagt
zu sagen ich glaube das ist ein ganz
zynischer effekt wenn man auf
wohlstandsverlust setzt um die umwelt zu
verbessern das gegenteil ist richtig in
armen ländern findet in der regel berger
klima und umweltschutz hat bedanke mich
jedenfalls erlebt für die debatte
angestoßen haben und ich merke man
müsste sie raus lösen und noch mal eine
ganze sendung allein zu dieser frage
machen danke schön aber ja das ist
natürlich auch etwas wo die gesellschaft
eine sehr unterschiedliche perspektive
hat ich gehe mal nach münchen zu emilia
ertler freier klar grüß gott
nicht mehr aber wir hören sie gut
ich bin rentnerin
ich habe eine kleine rente obwohl ich
schon gearbeitet habe und jetzt weil die
preise bei den ständig gestiegen sind
konnte ich mit meinem mann überhaupt
nicht mehr fordern nun in dem fall wenn
wir zum arzt gehen müssen dann müssten
wir mit den fahrern aber sonst nicht
jetzt feiern wir uns für diesen neuen
euro-pakt ich bin so sauer wenn die
leute sagen das ist überhaupt nicht so
toll und das ist nicht so gut angekommen
sie werden dann von leider die geld habe
sie können sich das leisten aber wir
können uns nicht leisten
und ich möchte nicht zum staat gehen
dass ich weiß nicht wofür noch geld
kriegen es geht auch um die
lebensmittelpreise die ständig in die
höhe gehen es gibt um heizung der
havarie liane lang überhaupt nicht
geholzt und trotzdem wir haben jedes
jahr immer mehr bezahlen müssen wofür es
eigentlich und wenn diese drei monate
dieser neuen euro da ist dann können wir
zufällig ein bisschen fahren sonst
überhaupt nicht und eigentlich die
politiker hätten anders denken sollen
dass die rentner zu völlig umsonst mit
öffentlicher dienst fahren dürfen
danke in frage so die frage ist bei der
rumba weil ich höher
steht dann einfach hand gehen ja ich bin
auch in sehr dankbar von hinaus
vielleicht sollte ich da mal darauf
anderen weil ich etwas gegen das neun
euro ticket gesagt ich denke ja also ich
also meiner meinung nach ist das 9 euro
ticket deswegen schlecht weil es eben
gerade auch die leute begünstigt die
sich problemlos leisten können mit dem
öffentlichen nahverkehr zum vollen preis
zu fahren das heißt es geht nicht um
menschen wie sie das ist überhaupt nicht
mein einwand sondern es geht mir darum
dass das nicht richtig verteilt ist dass
man halt zielgerecht und in der
richtigen stelle helfen zu mir kam jetzt
der gedanke es gibt ja die forderung
öffentlicher nahverkehr frei für halle
und die vielleicht ist ja die antwort ja
ich würde gern die nächsten zuschauer
noch annehmen vielleicht ist ja die
antwort auch für manche und für manche
sehr bestimmt ich bin gespannt was eine
was für eine debatte dann läuft wenn das
nur ein euro ticket ausläuft dankeschön
frei erkner und vermutlich der letzte in
der sendung ist klaus kirchner in essen
verkehrsunfällen guten tag in die runde
sie sind
zwischen frage und zwar die der größe
krisengewinnler ist dass der staat in
wenn die preise steigen nimmt er mehr
steuern hat aufgrund der preissteigerung
es wäre doch mal angebracht man eine
steuerreform die schon lange versprochen
ist die auch den den mittelstand
entlastet die uns alle entlastet
einerseits und andererseits war zu
gucken man braucht keine protz bauten in
der zeit das bundeskanzleramt soll für
sich hunderte millionen ausgebaut wird
dann zwar noch mit kostenseite sehen für
mich ist das wird einfach das problem
und man braucht da nicht diese brut
atemzug zu verteilen das ist meine frage
dass man sich wieder das problem richtig
angeht und mich so kleckerweise danke
danke herr gerne der staat profitiert
und soll was zurück der staat profitiert
aber das hatten wir ja auch bei allen
anruferinnen und anrufern tatsächlich
gehört das ist ja auch die große
sehnsucht nach nicht nur einer
zielgerichteten sondern nach einem
starken staat der auch zielgerichtet bei
den jeweiligen problemen unterstützen
kann und da haben wir ja auch schon
festgestellt es gibt ganz viele projekte
die im rahmen einer krise versucht
werden auszuprobieren damit sie
linderung verschaffen und hier ist ja
der große wunsch dass man a priori von
vornherein auch aus solchen fehlern
lernt und mit großen linien das eine
oder andere glas sieht und da gehört
eine steuerreform mit sicherheit
offensichtlich auch dazu bedanke mich
bedanke mich für die vielen
rückmeldungen heute bei der sendung per
telefon aber vor allem auch hier im netz
und dieses stichwort ausprobieren
gefällt mir also wenn von diesen bunten
strauß von maßnahmen was übrig bliebe
nämlich dass man sagt probiert geprüft
und verworfen oder weitergeführt dann
hätte es einen guten sinn gehabt
herzlichen dank einen wunderbaren
sonntagsschuss lassen sie es gut gehen
[Musik]